mm to mathematicians published a new
method to test for primes and finally
they found a fast way that was 100% this
is now one of the latest things so this
is called the AKS test and it's pretty
much a very similar idea to what we did
with the firm our little theorem is very
similar to that and the test is if
you've got a number P and we are going
to do this then I take X minus 1 to the
power P and then we're going to subtract
X to the P minus 1 all right so it's a
polynomial I'll show you an example in a
second if all coefficients are divisible
by P then P Prime and if they're not
it's composite it's 100% this test I'll
show you an example let's take X minus 1
cubed yeah let's do that X minus 1 cubed
so 3 is the number where twisted yeah 3
is the number we're testing we know it's
a prime don't we but we're going to test
it we're going to take X minus 1 cubed
to make it explicit X minus 1 by X minus
1 by X minus 1 ok multiply this out you
get a polynomial called X cubed minus 3x
squared 3x minus 1 that's what you get
now you're subtracting the X cubed I'm
told I'm told to do that and you're
what's that adding on the 1 so these
these disappear this says these numbers
are divisible by 3 if it is divisible by
3 3 is the number we're testing then it
is a prime if it's not divisible by 3 it
is not a prime and that's a 100% test so
this was really important this was huge
news when they published this 2002 they
published it is usually because it was a
fast test as well we could be made into
a fast test there's a little thing they
do just to make it a bit faster
because it does get quite difficult
these these polynomials get quite nasty
just make a little bit faster what they
did is X minus a for the power P minus X
to the P minus a so a is a number like
we had before and they said this was
equal to P lots of something plus here
you go little X minus I minus 1
multiplied by something so that's not
quite the same as a little bit different
this was actually faster to work with it
makes a faster calculation and for this
version you need to test a few
candidates or a here you just test a few
and if it passes that test then you can
determine that P which is what we're
trying to work out try and work that out
you can find its prime or not
mathematics is done all day every day
new mathematics is coming out all the
time
and only well I say recently twelve
years ago they finally solved the
problem it is still faster to do our
firm our test it's still faster to do
this but this is not outrageously slow
anymore it doesn't take us to the end of
the universe anymore
so we can actually run this test it's
slower than the therm our tests but 100%
true